WORKING-CLASS BLUES.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
"ANGLE."
WITH THE RUSSIA COLLUSION
FANTASIES GOING UP IN FLAMES,
DEMOCRATS ARE TRYING TO FIND NEW
MEANING IN THEIR POLITICAL LIVE
LIVES.
TO SATISFY THEIR LEFT-WING
CORPS, WELL, THEY ARE DABBLING
WITH SOCIALISM AND RACIALIZED IN
ALMOST EVERY ISSUE OUT THERE
IMAGINABLE.
THAT IS OBVIOUSLY NOT ENOUGH TO
ENACT IN 2020 BECAUSE OF MAY
STOKE THEIR RADICAL CORE
REPELS THE WORKING MY CLASS OF
VOTERS THAT ARE NOT IN THE
MILLIONS FOR DONALD TRUMP OR
2016.
SO I THINK DEMOCRATS ARE IN
SOMETHING OF A CONUNDRUM HERE.
FOR ALL THEIR BLUSTER ABOUT
TRUMP'S VULNERABILITY, THEY ARE
THE ONES WITH A BIG PROBLEM.
UNLESS YOU THINK STEELWORKERS
AND, LET'S SAY, THE RUST BELT
ARE CLAMORING FOR THIS MESSAGE.
>> WE HAVE A PRESIDENT TODAY WHO
IS A RACIST.
WHO IS A SEXIST.
WHO IS A HOMOPHOBE.
WHO IS A XENOPHOBE, AND WHO IS A
RELIGIOUS BIGOT.
THIS COUNTRY CONTINUES TO BE
PLAGUED BY INSTITUTIONAL RACISM
AND RACIAL INEQUALITY.
>> Laura: NOW ARE COAL MINERS
FAMILIES IN WEST VIRGINIA
EXCITED ABOUT THIS?
>> HUNDREDS OF YEARS OF THE
SLAVERY IN INSTITUTIONAL RACISM
HAVE CAUSED MASSIVE INEQUITY
AND HARM TO BLACK PEOPLE AND HAS
HELD BLACK COMMUNITIES BACK FOR
GENERATIONS FROM ACHIEVING THEIR
FULL POTENTIAL.
>> Laura: MODIFIED UNION
WORKERS IN MICHIGAN?
IS THIS THE APPROACH THEY HAVE
BEEN WAITING FOR?
>> OUR PLANET IS IN PERIL.
WE NEED TO BE BOLD.
THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE NOW THAT
ARE GOING BACK ON THE GREEN NEW
DEAL, THEY SAY IT'S IMPRACTICAL,
IT IS TOO EXPENSIVE, OH, IT'S --
IF WE USE TO GOVERN OUR DREAMS
THAT WAY, WE WOULD HAVE NEVER
GONE TO THE MOON.
>> Laura: FOR THEIR NEW ORACLE
IS PART SOCIAL MEDIA WAYS AND
PART SOCIALIST TRENDSETTER,
DEMOCRATS RISK AND EXODUS OF
WORKING-CLASS VOTERS.
>> THE IDEA THAT YOU CAN BE POOR
AND BENEFIT FROM THE COLOR OF
YOUR SKIN DOES NOT COMPUTE FOR A
LOT OF PEOPLE.
IT'S VERY PAINFUL TO ADMIT THAT
YOU HAD ADVANTAGES.
>> Laura: IN 2016, WHITE
VOTERS CONSTITUTED MORE THAN 74%
OF ALL VOTERS, ACCORDING TO PEW
RESEARCH.
REMEMBER, OBAMA DID VERY WELL IN
THE VOTING BLOC IN BOTH 2008 AND
2012.
YET SOME DEMOCRATS SEEM TO BE
ACTUALLY WORKING OVERTIME TO
SCARE OFF AS MANY WHITE MALE
VOTERS AS POSSIBLE.
>> IT WILL BE MUCH MORE POSSIBLE
GOING FORWARD IN THE WAY THAT I
TALK ABOUT OUR MARRIAGE AND ALSO
THE WAY I ACKNOWLEDGE OUR TRUTH
OF THE CRITICISM THAT I HAVE
ENJOYED WHITE PRIVILEGE.
ABSOLUTELY, UNDENIABLE.
I HAVE BEEN ARRESTED TWICE IN MY
LIFE.
THOSE MISTAKES DIDN'T END UP
DIVINING ME OR NARROWING MY
OPTIONS IN LIFE.
A LOT OF IT HAS TO DO WITH THE
FACT THAT I AM A WHITE MAN.
>> Laura: [LAUGHS]
UNBELIEVABLE.
EVEN OLD JOE BIDEN IS TRYING TO
PLAY RACHEL CATCH
RACIAL CATCH UP.
HE RECENTLY APOLOGIZED TO ANITA
HILL FOR THE WHITENESS OF THE
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
>> THERE WERE A BUNCH OF WHITE
GUYS.
SHE FACED A COMMITTEE THAT
DIDN'T FULLY UNDERSTAND WHAT IT
WAS ALL ABOUT.
TO THIS DAY, I REGRET I COULDN'T
COME UP WITH A WAY TO GET HER
THE KIND OF HEARING SHE
DESERVED.
>> Laura: THE LIBERAL MEDIA
ALSO KEEPS RAISE FRONT AND
CENTER.
THEY MAKE MORE SECRETIVE THE
BELIEF THAT BEING WHITE IS A
NEGATIVE AND RUNNING FOR OFFICE.
>> IS A TIME TO HAVE SOMEBODY OF
COLOR AND A WOMAN AT SOMEBODY
YOUNGER OR SOMEONE MORE
ESTABLISHMENT?
>> I THINK THE DEMOCRATS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY ARE GOING TO HELP
DECIDE THAT.
>> BUT AS A WHITE GUY, ARE YOU
TRYING TO CALCULATE WHETHER OR
NOT THIS IS THE RIGHT TIME FOR
YOU?
>> Laura: THEY ARE OBSESSED.
THE RACE AND DIVERSITY FOCUS
UNDOUBTEDLY COMES OFF TOO MANY
AMERICANS IS DEEPLY UNFAIR AND
ITSELF KIND OF RACIST.
NOW THESE VOTERS CALL THEMSELVES
BUT
BRIGHTER
THEMSELVES -- TRUMP SHOWED UP IN
2016 AND APPEALED DIRECTLY TO TH
2016 AND APPEALED DIRECTLY TO TS
2016 AND APPEALED DIRECTLY TO TE
FORGOTTEN AMERICANS.
>> THE FORGOTTEN MEN AND WOMEN
OF OUR COUNTRY WILL BE FORGOTTEN
NO LONGER.
EVERYONE IS LISTENING TO YOU
NOW.
>> Laura: SO WELL THE
DEPLORABLES FEEL MORE
COMFORTABLE WITH THE DEMOCRATS
NEW SELF-APPOINTED SPOKESMAN
FOR MORAL AND CULTURAL ISSUES?
>> OF ME BEING GAY WAS A CHOICE,
IT WAS HER CHOICE THAT WAS
MADE FAR, FAR ABOVE MY PAY GRADE
MADE FAR, FAR ABOVE MY PAY GRAD.
THAT IS WHAT I WISH THE
MIKE PENCES OF THE WORLD WOULD
UNDERSTAND.
IF YOU HAVE A PROBLEM WITH WHO I
AM, THE PROBLEM IS NOT WITH ME.
YOUR QUARREL, SIR, AS WITH MY
CREATOR.
>> Laura: IF THERE IS A POLL
THAT SHOWS THAT THIS FOCUS IS ON
THE TOP OF ANY LIST OF VOTERS'
CONCERNS, LET ALONE THE CONCERNS
OF WORKING-CLASS CATHOLIC AND HE
VOTERS, I MUST HAVE MISSED THAT
SURVEY.
AT LEAST ONE DEMOCRAT WHO KNOWS
A LITTLE BETTER ABOUT WINNING
NATIONAL ELECTIONS IS WARNING
THAT HIS PARTY IS IN DANGER WITH
ALL THESE INTRAPARTY LITMUS
TESTS.
>> WE START SOMETIMES CREATING
WHAT IS CALLED A CIRCULAR FIRING
SQUAD.
WHERE YOU ARE SHOOTING AT YOUR
ALLIES BECAUSE ONE OF THEM
IS STRAYING FROM PURITY ON THE
ISSUES, AND WHEN THAT HAPPENS,
TYPICALLY THE OVERALL EFFORT AND
MOVEMENT WEEKENDS.
>> Laura: CLEARLY TALKING
ABOUT REPARATIONS, GREEN NEW
DEAL CAME OF THAT KIND OF STUFF.
THE DEMOCRATS ABOUT TO BE A
CIRCULAR FIRING SQUAD HE WAS
REFERENCING HAS CAUSED EVEN
CANDIDATES WITH THE BEST CHANCE
TO KILL APPEALING TO
WORKING-CLASS WHITES, LIKE
JOE BIDEN, TO MOVE OUR LAST.
LET'S FACE IT, THEY ARE ZERO
APPETITE AT THIS POINT FOR A
MODERATE LIKE HOWARD SCHULTZ.
THAT IS SOME HAPPENING.
AND OF COURSE THE ELEPHANT IN
THE ROOM AND THIS ENTIRE DEBATE
IF THE DEMOCRATS CAN ATTRACT
THESE TYPE OF WORKING-CLASS
VOTERS, IS THAT THE WORD
"ECONOMY" -- IT'S PAINTED ON THE
SIDE OF THE BIG FAT ELEPHANT IN
THE ROOM.
AND THE ECONOMY, ACCORDING TO
PEW'S LATEST SURVEY, IS STILL
THE NUMBER ONE ISSUE FOR
AMERICANS NATIONWIDE.
IN A NEW GALA POLL, TRUMP SCORES
IN A NEW GALA POLL, TRUMP SCORE9
IN A NEW GALA POLL, TRUMP SCORE%
IN A NEW GALA POLL, TRUMP SCOREA
IN A NEW GALA POLL, TRUMP SCOREP
IN A NEW GALA POLL, TRUMP SCOREO
IN A NEW GALA POLL, TRUMP SCOREI
IN A NEW GALA POLL, TRUMP SCOREH
REPUBLICAN VOTERS ON HIS
HANDLING OF THE ECONOMY.
SO HOW ON EARTH ARE DEMOCRATS
GOING TO BEAT THE STRONGEST
ECONOMY IN THE G7, WITH RECORD
LOW UNEMPLOYMENT, ALMOST 500,000
NEW MANUFACTURING JOBS CREATED?
WHAT IS THEIR ARGUMENT FOR
BEATING THAT?
IN THE LAST 12 MONTHS, BUT WAGES
HAVE RISEN BY 3.4%.
HEADLINES LIKE THIS WERE JUST
NOT SEEN DURING EIGHT YEARS OF
OBAMA.
BLUE-COLLAR VOTERS FINALLY
GETTING A RAISE, WORKERS ARE
MAKING MORE MONEY, SO DEMOCRATS,
WHAT ARE THEY GOING TO SAY?
THEY HAVE A RACE, SOCIALISM, AND
THEY HAVE ONE OTHER TALKING
POINTS LEFT IN THEIR MANUAL.
>> WHAT ABOUT THE ECONOMY FOR
THE PEOPLE WHO DON'T HAVE
CHOICES OR DON'T HAVE THE
EDUCATION THAT I HAVE?
>> PROBABLY UNEMPLOYMENT IS WAY
DOWN, ACROSS SECTORS.
>> HELP ME OUT HERE.
>> UNEMPLOYMENT IS NOT THE ONLY
STATISTICS AND THERE NEEDS TO BE
AN INFORMED DEBATE ABOUT THE
ECONOMY THAT NEEDS TO LOOK AT
INCOME INEQUALITY.
>> AT A TIME OF HISTORIC INCOME
INEQUALITY, SHOULD BE ASKED TO
BE A GREATER SHARE.
>> WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
GENERATIONAL POVERTY, GENERAL
DISPOSITION.
>> A NATION OF MASSIVE
INEQUALITY.
>> MARKETS ABOUT RULE IS ABOUT
THE RICH TAKING ALL, IT'S ABOUT
THE POWERFUL GETTING ALL ABOUT.
>> Laura: INCOME INEQUALITY, A
LONG-WINDED WAY OF SAYING THAT.
>> THIS ARGUMENT IS A LOSER.
WAGES FOR MOST AMERICANS ARE
GOING UP NOW, NOT BECAUSE OF
GOVERNMENT MANDATE, BUT BECAUSE
OF TRUMP'S POLICIES.
WHAT ARE THEY?
LOWER TAXES, LESS REGULATION,
PRESSURE ON CHINA TRADE
CHEATING, AND THE TIGHTER LABOR
MARKET FOR ALL WORKING PEOPLE.
SO THE DEMOCRATS' ANSWER IS
HIGHER TAXES, MORE REGULATIONS,
AND MORE LOW WAGE LABOR IS
FLOODING INTO AMERICA.
THAT IS EXACTLY THE OPPOSITE OF
WHAT MOST WORKING-CLASS VOTERS
WANT.
OH, OH, FOR THOSE LIBERALS WHO
PUT ALL THEIR HOPES AND BEING
SAVED BY CHANGING DEMOGRAPHY,
HERE'S A NEWS FLASH: THIS IS THE
PERCENTAGE OF WHITE NONCOLLEGE
GRADUATE VOTERS IN A HANDFUL OF
KEY STATES, AND I WANT.
THEY MAKE UP 60% OF THE
POPULATION.
IN MICHIGAN, 54% OF THE
POPULATION, OHIO, 55%,
PENNSYLVANIA, 51%, AND
WISCONSIN, 58%.
TRUMP DOES REALLY WELL WITH THAT
GROUP OBVIOUSLY.
NOW EVEN A PROGRESSIVE WRITER
FOR "THE ATLANTIC" NOTED THE
FOLLY OF THE DEMOGRAPHY WILL
SAVE US THINKING, SAYING, THIS
IS WISHFUL THINKING.
FIRST, THE U.S. WON'T BE
MAJORITY MINORITY UNTIL ABOUT
2045.
MOREOVER, EVEN IN 2040, 37
STATES WILL REMAIN MAJORITY
WHITE.
TODAY'S RADICALIZED DEMOCRAT
PARTY HAS MOVED FURTHER AWAY
FROM THE VOTERS THEY NEED TO WIN
IN 2020.
THEY STILL HAVE NO CLUE.
IT'S UNBELIEVABLE, REALLY, HOW
TO SPEAK TO THE WORKING-CLASS
WHITE VOTERS, LET ALONE HOW TO
GET THEIR VOTES.
THEY LOOK DOWN THERE ELITIST
NOSES ON ALL WORKING PEOPLE OF
ALL BACKGROUNDS.
AND THEIR VALUES, COME ON.
THEY PRETTY MUCH LOOKED ON THEIR
NOSES AT EVERYTHING ABOUT THE
WORKING-CLASS PEOPLE.
NO SLICK ADVERTISING SLOGANS OR
CAMPAIGNS OR CANDIDATES WHO TRY
TO OUT-CHRISTIAN THE TRUMP -LIKE
DEEP DISTRUST OF MANY WORKING-CA